The titanosaur is no longer
As the largest animal to roam the earth.
You think such an impressive presence would be almost invincible.
How did this Titan of a creature finally meet its demise?
It seems even the mightiest.
In fall.
Is a titanosaur.
How did they end up on every continent?
And why did they disappear?
This is what if,
and here's what would happen if Titanic sores never went extinct.
Titanosaurs were part of a diverse group of dinosaurs called sauropods from the
Greek, meaning lizard foot.
Their enormous skeletal remains along with immense lizard.
Footprints have been found all over the world.
This global domination is both imposing and incredible.
So how did they end up on every continent? Well,
their extraordinary geographical distribution had to do with the splitting
of the subcontinent gun Dwana that took place at the end of the Cretaceous
period.
These long neck giants hitched a ride when this enormous landmass parted
and they lumbered onward to new Terrafirma.
The largest titanosaur was discovered in Argentina in 1987
appropriately dubbed the Argentina Saurus for this location.
They lived about 100 million years ago.
They were estimated to weigh up to 100 tons with a length ranging
between 30 and 40 meters,
and as tall as 15 to 20 meters, for some comparison,
picture the towering height of a seven story building,
or the great Sphinx of Giza throw in the mass of 12
Asian elephants or 2200 kilograms.
That's more than a Boeing seven 37 maximum takeoff weight.
And even the lengthy stretch of an official NBA basketball court at 29
meters would only hold three quarters of the creature's body
because of their massive size.
They were able to cover a lot of ground without moving excessively and expending
too much energy with top speeds,
averaging only around eight kilometers per hour, a social bunch.
They traveled in small hurts and needed to continuously be on the move to fuel
their gigantic appetites. So how did they die out?
Well,
their fate was sealed at 66 million years ago when asteroid struck the earth,
not only was this the end of the Titanic source,
but it also wiped out 75% of life on earth.
Yet if these Titans managed to write out changing times,
they would have needed to overcome several catastrophic global extinctions.
First they'd have to sidestep the asteroid that wiped them out.
Originally then persevere when global warming spikes global
temperatures, 55 million years later,
and also plow through the ice age 2.6 million years ago,
if they were here present day consuming so much plant life,
where would that leave us humans on the food chain,
evolving Titanic sores could deplete the ecosystem of vegetation
entirely and might be forced to become carnivores and adapt to their
ever-changing environment. Well, they may not become pure meat eaters.
They could become omnivores.
And if they developed a taste for meat who would be on the menu,
you and I,
this could create a scary ripple effect in the food chain and possibly cause
many species to die off. Since it's possible,
we could be considered prey. We would be forced to live in the tree tops,
maybe in a magical kingdom like indoor, maybe not.
Our new form of transportation could be the vines swinging from tree to
tree, like Tarzan to avoid the treachery if the open jaws below.
But what if humans were able to tame the tight
picture, happy, helpful. Titanosaur on a construction site,
working the ground look familiar,
or you could see them being useful and marching into battle like the heritage
rims on giant elephants and the Lord of the rings,
taking out everything in their path and imagine how many
mouths one of these giants could feed the titanosaur could become
a source of food for humans and solve world hunger.
This might force them to flee land and head to the water,
living off a plethora of underwater Marine life plankton. Wait,
could it be possible that titanosaur is actually alive today,
hiding in the murky depth, Suffolk coast of Inverness, Scott,
perhaps sharing the water with another prehistoric behemoth,
the Moses Saurus. Well,
that's a story for another. What if.